l'activité de ce groupe merci la parole
est à monsieur nicolas sansu merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre voici quelques semaines
l'insee indiqué que la pauvreté
repartaient à la hausse dans notre pays
avec 14 3 % de nos concitoyens vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté soit près de 9
millions de personnes
derrière ces chiffres froids il ya des
drames humains je pense à cette jeune
mère de famille isolée qui travaillent à
temps partiel et ne sais pas quel noël
elle offrira à ses enfants
je pense à ce couple de retraités
modestes qui vit reclus car ne pouvant
pas s'écarter d'un euro ou à ce jeune
homme ballotté de travail précaires en
stage et qui à 30 ans doit retourner
chez ses parents dans le même temps et
contrairement à ce qu'affirme la droite
jamais la france d'abriter autant de
millionnaires jamais les inégalités
n'ont été aussi forte
jamais les dividendes versés à une
petite caste n'ont été aussi élevés
d'ailleurs les 500 plus grandes fortunes
s'en tire à bon compte puisque l'état
lui-même à rembourser madame bettencourt
première fortune de france 2 61 millions
d'euros suivant en cela la logique du
bouclier fiscal l'exonérant ainsi de
l'impôt sur la fortune
certes le gouvernement a mis en place le
relèvement des minima sociaux ou la
prime d'activité mais pour cette
dernière plus de 40 % des travailleurs
qui ont droit n'en font pas la demande
aussi alors que le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité on peut avoir encore
augmenté et qu'au total chaque employeur
aura reçu 150 euros par mois dette
publique pour chaque salarié payé au
salaire minimum
il est aujourd'hui injustifiable de ne
pas augmenter le smic au delà de
l'augmentation légale de 0 93 % au 1er
janvier prochain le smic augmentera
moins que la croissance avec 37 centimes
d'euros de plus par jour
il ne jouera pas son rôle de soutien à
la consommation ni son rôle de
déclencheurs des augmentations des
autres salaires voire des pensions et
allocations
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
travailleurs dans leur ensemble c'est
une erreur économique c'est un gâchis
social
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le premier
ministre qu'une réelle augmentation du
smic aurait été un élément de confiance
de cohésion de justice pour notre peuple
qui aspire à l'égalité en contrecarrant
ainsi les divisions qui se font jour
je vous remercie
la parole est à mme damien derrière elle
comme au ministre du travail de l'emploi
de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
nicolas sansu permettez moi de vous
happe rappeler en effet quelques faits
et nous avons tout à fait conscience de
la situation particulièrement difficile
notamment des ménages les plus modestes
dans notre pays et d'ailleurs vous
l'avez entendu un instant à travers la
question portée par la députée louve
agit à travers les exonérations d'impôts
que nous avons mises en oeuvre il y as
eux mêmes reproches que justement ces
deux baisses d'impôts n'ont été qu'en
direction des ménages les plus pauvres
ceux que nous assumons bien évidemment
quelle est la réalité s'agissant du smic
en effet dans une période de reprise
et alors même que ses 1,6 million de
travailleurs qui sont au smic sont à 85
% dans des tpe et dans des pme
nous avons considéré que qu'il ne
convenait pas de d'augmenter leur masse
salariale au delà de l'inflation
est ce pour autant nous ne sommes pas
notamment particulièrement mobilisé sur
les ménages les plus modestes justement
permettez moi de rappeler quelques faits
la revalorisation du rsa de plus de 10%
le fait de sortir de la peau de la
revenu beaucoup de nos concitoyens
le fait qu'au 1er janvier 2010 7,5
millions de foyers qui paieront en
moyenne 200 euros par mois et vous me
parliez justement de la prime d'activité
je vous remercie de l'avoir évoquée dans
le cadre de votre question mais
permettez moi d'y revenir précisément en
effet contrairement au rsa activité
nous avons augmenté le taux de recours à
la prime d'activité et du secours rsa
activité seul 30% des personnes ne la
demandez aujourd'hui ses 60 % dont nous
avons encore une marge de manoeuvre mais
il s'agit de 3,7 me 3 7 millions de
foyers qui en bénéficient dont cinq cent
mille jeunes je vous rappelle qu'à peine
8000 jeunes bénéficier du rsa jeunes à
l'époque
concrètement pour un célibataire au smic
c'est un treizième mois donc vous le
voyez bien que nous avons accès
justement pour plus de justice sociale
l'ensemble par le levier fiscal et par
le levier également de la prime
d'activité pour améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat des travailleurs les plus
modestes